I was reading about some of your
influences and I know Metallica is a big
uh big influence to you master up
puppets I I love these guys and you got
to tour with them right I mean that must
have been a party yeah huh I remember
our manager walking on the bus and being
like so guys
I've been so excited to give you this
news it had to come out to the tour and
give it to you in person
you've been asked to do all summer with
Metallica and we oh my God I mean dream
come true I love that story when Chester
went out on stage during their
performance and started I don't know
rollerblading or skateboarding through
there yeah and so nobody had ever
pranked them nobody had ever pranked
them on stage well what balls that I
took I could see Lars beating him over
the head with a symbols by the way it
was like four of us I think so we went
out the the gag was that we wanted to do
something that was like like so their
show was always so tough and dark
everything was like tough and dark and
so we're like What would be this like
least tough least dark thing to do I
mean like we we were we ended up going
out with a picnic basket and like little
sandwiches and drinks and Chester has
skateboard and he skated out on stage
and then we like walked out onto their
stage they were playing I think master
puppets and we set up a picnic right
above Lars and we had gotten the good we
guys are go ahead from their head as
security D to do it that he promised he
wouldn't like take us out yeah I mean
but the guys laughing I mean like they
were laughing what they're playing
Master button turning around like
laughing at us Metallica is like Joe
Pesci like you're like oh is he gonna
think I'm funny or is he gonna [__]
beat my ass into the ground it's weird
to be able to say that we knew them just
well enough to know that James wasn't
Gonna Knock my teeth out like